Jeremy renner's snow plow accident was
shocking to say the least and now the
star himself has given fans an update
about his condition Renner took to
Instagram on Tuesday January 3rd to
offer up his very first message to the
public since his serious snowplow
accident the star has been described as
being in critical but stable condition
following an accident involving the
snowplow on January 1st police officials
say Renner was near Mount Rose Highway
in Reno Nevada when the accident
occurred and that he suffered a serious
injury to his chest as Mr Renner always
does those private roads he was being a
great neighbor and he was plowing those
roads for his neighbor because up there
again they had three feet it was
subsequently reported that Renner
underwent surgery for blunt chest trauma
and Orthopedic injuries a representative
sent out a statement saying Jeremy's
family would like to express their
gratitude to the incredible doctors and
nurses looking after him they are also
tremendously overwhelmed and
appreciative of the outpouring of love
and support from his fans while while
things have appeared to be proceeding
smoothly with renner's treatment and the
start of his recovery many fans have
nonetheless been anxious to hear more
about how the star is doing thankfully
it now seems that the actor has
recovered enough to manage a reassuring
personal update on his own well-being as
well as the heartfelt thank you to
everyone via social media this has
prompted a deluge of support in the
comments on his Instagram page in the
new post the actor included a single
photo of himself in the hospital in
which he is severely bruised and hooked
up to medical equipment nevertheless
very much alive in a caption he wrote
thank you all for your kind words I'm
too messed up now to type but I send
love to you all an update from Renner
himself has proven to be a moment of
comfort for fans and what has otherwise
been an uneasy and concerning series of
updates regarding the actor's condition
the post garnered a startling amount of
attention amassing more than 5 million
seven hundred thousand likes and 230 000
comments within roughly 18 hours of
being posted while the actor remains in
critical condition it hopefully won't be
too long before fans get another update
about renner's recovery not long after
Renner broke his silence on the third
fans started flocking to his post to
show support one fan commented happy to
see you awake another said was really
worried about you even if we don't know
each other get well soon another fan
commented thinking of you every day man
sending love and prayers to my favorite
hero many fans were quick to invoke
renner's role as Hawkeye and the MCU in
their well wishes as one said get better
Hawkeye we all send our love and support
many of renner's colleagues from
throughout the film and entertainment
industry also took the time to comment
on the post fellow Marvel star Chris
Pratt said continued prayers your way
brother meanwhile Vanessa Hudgens wrote
sending so much love and healing and
actor Tasha Smith declared you're a
tough mother you know what and I love
you for it all in addition to showing
support many users and celebrities
expressed their happiness that Renner
was well in enough to provide his own
update celebrity trainer and actor Jason
Walsh posted damn brother I was really
worried about you good to see your face
and renner's tag co-star Isla Fisher
commented phew I'm so happy you made
this post sending you so much love and
healing energy we love you
[Music]